[Rires]
seul contente de voir
je suis à dire je suis vraiment très
très content de voir si le prêt mais je
vois que tu m'avais complètement zappé
je sais que tu dois partir à 20h pile ce
soir je n'écouterai donc
je suis content de te voir je tenais
je tenais à te casser un à damien c'est
pas la mission frère je laime il le sent
prêt et je viens de voir
tarek ben ou dalida
c'est direct boudani orwellienne
dalida voilà à un peu voulu aller voir
tu vois toi
moi j'ai reconnu au reer déjà là je vois
patrice laffont qui tient la main de
passe partout
cela dit mchugh bluff
j'ai bien fait mélanie maietti compter
la cible un cocktail à base de détecter
des objets thème bien éclater aime bien
être la dalle pupitre à anticiper malin
tu es là tu anticipes et
bien sûr mon frère mon la wii me tiens
talent et que gm il le sait voilà tout
ce qu'il fait il cartonne et le mérite
c'est mon tarek boudali d'amour
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi en fait je ne sais pas
on m'a dit est ce que tu peux mettre une
perruque pour faire boudali d'à côté
c'est pas non plus nommé la perruque est
belle c'est à dire vraiment moins cher
parce qu'en fait la team est pas dans la
bad on se disait le mec
chilemba il est content et tu avec
boudali que j'aime la rive voilà je suis
fou de semaine cartonne mon chéri à
chaque fois je suis tellement heureux
que tu tu kartonn d'acheter un combi
[Musique]
et tarek c voilà ces voiles à ccc la
famille à chaque fois qu on vient nous
voir il ya nous voir les séries je vais
demander à matthieu mabin branche entend
donner une deuxième chance non non non
je n'arrive pas je vais
encore
le rideau à bluff tient la file assez
regarde toi on regarde d'abord regarde
d'accord et a compris concept pas match
c'est bon ça se fait pas je crois que
l'état leur tampon la raison qui est
vraiment derrière le
donc assez drôle
aucune idée
j'ai on regarde ce que je peux
regretter mais vas-y toi m'a dit
je connais pas son nom mais je vois un
syndicaliste avec un chanteur
farthouat beat la barre 80e
minute pour dire ce que je vois
on dénote mafieux sa déléguée syndicale
3 je vois à
big flo et au niveau lives
et au liban il n'y a pas de jeu
maintenant on est nuls à ch
c'est vraiment messi
et pourquoi comment tu peux non mais je
viens de comprendre le truc en fait faut
donner un faux truc ben oui
[Applaudissements]
et
aussi nul devant un jour possible quoi
mais c'est pas possible ressaisis-toi
monteiro seat au hockey aussi si tout
cas c'est tout ok c'est tout ce que tu
as à dire alors du mois dans les bras
je voudrais qu'on accueille ce soir ceux
qui sont avec m bah voilà
est très heureux que fait très longtemps
qu'on les a eus ce que font les a pas
laissé le plateau ce sont des frères
l'album qui vient de sortir est
incroyable ils ont énormément travaillé
on les a pas vus pendant deux ans
faisant 230 ou copé ni sur les réseaux
ouais et en télévision rien ma mykonos
il n'y était pas
sont avec nous ce soir sont accompagnés
d'olive olives
mission big flo et oli soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
m
[Applaudissements]
non non
la cabine a dit
nicholas très très bien les missions des
parisiens mais c'est pas une trame se
mettent les adore j'ai même vu dans les
terres inconnues a pas longtemps je
faisais même pas reconnu mais c'est sûr
que si mais savait lui qui vous cacher
alors voyez un syndicaliste qui vous
cacherai pas bien des nouvelles d'un
syndicat 17 malins y
avait plus de monde
la veuve mais c'est vrai beaucoup mais
c'est pas toi toi tu va profiter de
l'été pour poser les nouvelles rideau il
faut regarder comme ça mais
sans déconner c'est un
cachet l'on sait très bas mais pas très
grand et de cacher ma mère est une merde
mais se dit attentif lolli
vous avez menti s'est pas vu mais bon
c'est bon
ça plaît un peu bon c'est pas 3 rue des
faits quoi on a bossé sur l'album a
beaucoup de boulot aimerait beaucoup de
boulot un peu de vacances j'ai écouté
laissons donc j'ai vu que en fait vous
avez quand même qui fit enfin vous êtes
vous le public vous a manqué c'est ce
que vous a manqué sur le sort de m on
arrête on a réglé nos trucs aussi on a
pris le temps pour nous prendre un peu
le bilan de tout ce qu'on avait fait ces
dernières années des raisons ça fait du
bien vrai de sa 11e pole depuis fait et
c'est la famille les amis et là aussi
reproché est la seule pour faire ça la
non là on va envoyer pendant longtemps
et de nous on est sur la scène de mercy
exa sortir d'album donc le retour demain
à l'accord arina pour un concert et non
il ya toujours votre papa qui était
présent
il ya des poules un peu moins mais sinon
il prend un peu
comme les amis que tu es venu chez mon
père quand même sur un lac pour
téléphoner je revois ces images
incroyables c'était magique et je
mettrai faire de l'art comme en tout cas
avant l'album c'est une bombe à
giroussens shades of franchement les
paroles fin c'est extraordinaire hier
soir deux ans d'absence ça vous a
magnifié vous arrêter mais ça vous était
pas merci beaucoup c'est très près
encore ses fruits au meilleur c'est très
bien de ces normes ida pourquoi vous a
manqué le match il nous a manqué aussi
bas même litige que s'agit d'inventer
une fin la mission là j'ai envie qu'on
boive albert
contre-attaqué de pages fait pas lourd
j'ai passé l'été avec beaucoup de
passes croisées c'est sûr comme d'hab
sûr c'est que tu connais bien sûr pas
des big bang je rappelle ce trip ping
pong chérèque on a été pas mal ça vu que
c'est pas dégueu et un style particulier
de type annuler ce jour-là toulousaine
tuerait dante street king kong je sais
pas si tu pouvais retourner m'arrive un
truc et comme l'été wu
a tué par une balle tu joues des têtes
baleine
mais il ya de tout enthousiasme et on
vous dévoilera pas mais je vous le dis
autour de la table de big bang il ya de
tout kai eide est grisé côté vu des gens
mais oui c'est à dire qu'il peut y avoir
je vous le dis mais d'avoir des hauts de
seine dark eye par des acteurs très
connus des humoristes des chanteurs et
poètes des politiques on le sait s'il y
avait patrick abry d'aider des
politiques même des billets pour
l'afrique comme avoir des ministres qui
joue à une émission c'est que savaient
les missions de fois va gronder
moi je me souviens quand je suis arrivé
chez toi à l'arrivée j'ai vu un
politique ga sportive monsieur espèrent
poser mais on aurait dit une sorte de
sketches blasphème étaient tous réunis
là bas il avait un gars il avait pas un
ami je suis radié en train de prendre
une fléchette dans le cul
paire de puces bong était contre le mur
d'ilva dimanche à laguna seca
nous là c'est pas une bananeraie voilà
et donc voilà il a vu plein de monde
mais soutenir pour mener cet été ouais
l'a7 était stationné leurs
estimations passe te voir à la famille
et tu nous as toujours social que le
début je suis tellement content de vous
revoir parce que dirait que c'est sain
c'est un truc de fou et l'envol aura
manqué de vous ré entendre à la radio tu
as ça fait du bien plaisir fait entendez
des gens les anciens sont messiriya les
anecdotes sur la radio je me rappelle un
jour série limay yvelines radio exit m3
vous passez pas sur cette radio et
resterait il appelle le peuple et
appelle le patron de la radio en mode je
suis avec big flo lilas pourquoi tu pas
que ce soit le centre sérieux le gars
est oui je sais
prendre cette radio j
je ne vois toujours défendu et soutenu à
chaque fois qu'on voit ça nous rappelle
bien à bien faire des tours de voitures
en sont on adore on m'a même dans les
magasins la borne à ping pong il adore
voilà on adore c'est notre jeu sera
contée
révéla c'est une ambiance vacances c'est
vrai tu nous as connu il ya sept ans
premier album tout jeune qui nous avait
invités au resto je me rappelle c'est
qu'on commence à avoir des petits coups
de vieux on croise des des jeunes je
suis tu vois j'utilise deux prochaines
étapes à brûler alors ils ont 18 ans ils
nous disent ah je vous écoute depuis que
j'ai 12 ans je voudrais que depuis que
j'ai commencé
à faire ce troisième rideau à bluff et
je vais demander à matthew
g le faire tout seul je faire tout seul
maintenant je crois qu'on n'est jamais
mieux servi que par soi même patrick non
et
je savais même pas c'est notre je savais
même pas
les mecs ça sert à quoi il ya derrière
rachid arhab
déplaçons même à rachid arhab si rachid
arhab déguisé en ml région avec une très
belle cacahuètes
mais ça n'avait pas
bu ou bien il ya
deux stars américaines
tidjy jackson 1 le neveu de michael
jackson et nico minaj
c'est la version low cost de nicki minaj
body qui nique aux minarets d'arabe et
les gars je vous le dis il ya vraiment
une star internationale derrière ouvrez
le rideau ouvrez moi ce [ __ ] de rideau
à il allait voir les lip automatique
[Applaudissements]
les bancaires ont ri kluba ouais c'est
pas fort sans rigoler bah ouais c'est
d'ailleurs là la carte et la quinte la
cat et là il a su plus tôt les trois
tables à merci et je fais très heureux
d'être venu nous voir génial fou de lui
les beaux et
nicolas pernikoff qu'il a alors ces deux
minutes voilà deux minutes y'a tiji
jackson merci data
merci elle est sympa
l'allergie tu sera en concert à paris
les 24 26 juin comme il jouait au
théâtre de la contrescarpe puis à lyon
le 2 juillet londres le 9 juillet et
amsterdam 16 juillet ton dernier album
acoustique session
acoustique
chinois huawei
steek sa section il faut personnes plus
sexy bas où vous avez gardé section
merci je l'adorais sera derniers mois
dans la dans les gares n'ont rien mais
les trains les voies à 2 6 8 9 non mais
qui j voudrais dire album allait voir
dijon conserve c'est une énorme star
c'est une douleur qui nous fait ce soir
jim
webb était pas comme un pouvoir tiges et
bah si évidemment jackson je regarde
toujours tâche n ont plus
l on regarde toujours d'âge
jackson l'album tourne et qu'on allait
le voir en concert et franchement il a
hélas pas changé et est toujours aussi
beau il est beau gbagbo arrête pas
vaincu c'est aymeric en même temps tu
apparais comme un temps mykonos mykonos
été
la muse hôtel
tout doux tout comme atouts méconnus ce
[Musique]
we would have fun
à auguste
j'ai une amie si jamais il veut j'ai une
amie qui fait visiter paris pour toutes
les stars elle a fait de pierce brosnan
tous annales fait que les stars il veut
il est certes non c'est le louvre privé
tout ça si jamais il veut c'est une
visite privée avec quelqu'un va là qu'il
ya c'est que ma mère en cours maiko aux
essais
m'a toujours
dit
il en train de te le dire la
lie en train de te le dire et je suis
sûr
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]